merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Philippe fait
sur le député je vous remercie je vous
remercie de mettre le focus d'abord sur
le handicap et ensuite sur les femmes en
situation de handicap sur l'égalité
homme-femme et sur les violences faites
aux femmes en situation de handicap
alors oui les femmes en situation de
handicap sont deux fois plus victimes
que les autres de violences sexuelles
ces glaçons oui être une femme et en
situation de handicap c'est la double
peine et je ne peux pas et nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter
nous travaillons avec Isabelle Rome
pour en plus de l'accès aux droits
communs bien entendu qui concerne ces
femmes et c'est heureux à déployer des
mesures concrètes sur le terrain la
prévention et la détection des violences
demandent nécessairement d'aller vers
ces femmes trop souvent exclues des
parcours traditionnels par exemple un
améliorant le suivi gynécologique des
femmes handicapées un travail de
sensibilisation sur la vie affective et
sexuelle et sur la question du
consentement et de la violence est menée
par exemple aussi la formation des
professionnels des secteurs
médico-social et sanitaires dans le
domaine des luttes contre les violences
savoir détecter les signaux repérer les
situations de violence est absolument
essentielle alors le dispositif on dit
gynéco mis en oeuvre dans trois régions
répond à ces à ces sujets et je souhaite
véritablement qu'il soit généralisé dans
notre pays et puis l'égalité homme-femme
elle passe bien sûr par l'accès à
l'autonomie
la décongélisation de la hache que vous
avez voté cet été va dans ce sens nous
devons veiller à l'accès également les
galaxies à la formation à l'emploi et
par l'autonomie et bien les femmes en
situation de handicap comme toutes les
femmes et bien seront plus plus
indépendantes et plus en sécurité et
enfin vous évoquez le sujet merci